Hello, friends from the future. It is metal
Monday, so that means I will be joined
by two of my favorite Equinix metal heads
to look over ways of bootstrapping your servers.
So we'll look at earlier in previous weeks,
we looked at ways to
bring up Equinix metal servers, and now we're
going to do something with them or at
least get them ready to do something.
Today, I'll be joined by
McKay and
Tom.
Hey. Hey.
Good Monday morning afternoon. How are you both?
Yeah. I'm doing alright. Thank you. Not too
bad. I'm starting my day with a livestream
with you two. That would be living the
dream, my friends.
Perfect.
Suck up.
I gotta keep make sure you keep inviting
me back.
Alright. So what what what are we what
are we each doing here today?
Well, I'm gonna kick off and kick
us off and show how
to provision
your
server
with Ansible and and go ahead and install
install it as an NGINX
server and get you up and running.
Everybody else wanna say what they're doing or
just jump in?
Yeah. Sure. I'll be look yep.
No. You go first.
I'll be look I'll be looking at doing
the same with Terraform and Cloud in it.
And I,
go figure, I'm doing pretty much the same.
So I will be using
following on from what I did last week
using preliminary automate the bare metal. I'll now
be using the user data to provision
SaltStack which will then handle the bit strappy
process. So we've got three awesome tools all
doing hopefully close enough to the same thing.
You wanna share your screen, Tom? Tom, you
are on mute.
Perfect. I'm gonna jump in right now.
Alright. So you can see here, I've got
our UI so that we can track the
process and I've got no servers yet.
What I have here is, we've created a
project just called demo.
Within it, we have, we have the commands
to provision,
and we set up the Ansible tasks
of creating
an Ubuntu device. You can see right here
that we've already put in our SSH key.
Can you just put in on that, please,
Tom? I can.
Can you see now? Is that good?
Yeah.
We've got our project ID which I found
right here when you're using Edge Metal or
Equinix Metal. You can see behind the project,
there's a full project ID. I copied that,
brought it over. I'm creating
Metal Monday live.
I went ahead and decided we're gonna run
Ubuntu 18 o four,
picked our server size as a c three
medium, and I am gonna do this out
in out of the bay. What we set
up in the, user data here because what
we have to do is we have to
run a local Ansible install to
install Ansible
on the server once it's created so that
Ansible can then
install
NGINX.
So we're getting really meta here. Right?
And what we have here, we're gonna go
on and update
the server once it's up. We're gonna get
we're gonna pull in Ansible, and we're gonna
clone a guest that we created.
So in addition to our local inventory, which
tells Ansible what to run locally on our
machine,
we have set up a guest with an
inventory that's just setting our route as the
Ansible user as route, the Ansible host as
local host, and the Ansible connection as local
so that everything is being deployed directly onto
the server.
And then within our main we've got our
main dot yaml, which is telling Ansible exactly
what to do. So with that, we're gonna
just run
the Ansible playbook create that we have,
and we will watch this.
Ansible, the error arguments required.
Yeah. So it should be Ansible playbook dash
I then inventory fail and then We forgot
the inventory file. Yep. Yeah.
Here.
This is why I don't do live demos.
Right?
So let's see here.
Like, want want me to change want me
to change your life for the better? Yeah.
Alright. Well, I hit control u.
Control u. Alright. And then control r.
And then type ansible.
And then hit control r again.
And again.
And again
until you find the command.
It's not there.
Okay. Control
c.
Just
it out.
Alright. So let's go here. We've got
it's a playbook I.
And we're gonna just pull the inventory file,
which is in the root. Right? Inventory.
Mhmm. K.
And then it should just be the path
to your playbook. So based on that directory
tree I see there, I think it's like
dot slash provision slash task Yep. Slash playbook
create.
Book
create
dot yaml.
Phew. And we are in business.
Okay. Little hiccup from a computer restart, but
we are good now. Let me refresh this.
We should see after we've got
it failed. Can you zoom in on that,
please? Yeah. It should say my API token.
Oh, yeah. You'll need to export that. It's
required. So let's stop sharing while I get
my API token.
Welcome to intermission.
We have this all set up.
Let's see.
That's the joy of doing You got some
have some intermission music, maybe something like Ramstein
or something.
No. There's a track from an offspring album,
actually
called intermission. And I I well, I used
to be a DJ in an eight club,
I used to play that all the time
to really piss people off.
Let's see.
My
somehow my token disappeared.
Let's try.
Get a new one real quick.
I don't know if this is gonna play
actually.
Do you hear that? You I we don't
hear it.
No.
Damn you, computer.
Alright. Got my new API key. Now we're
gonna just export it real quick in terminal.
Okay. Now let's share screen again,
and we'll give this a second go.
I've got confidence in you, Tom.
Alright. Here we go.
Okay.
Packet API token. I've got the API token.
Wait. You flashed it now. You might as
well just share it and delete it. I
might as well. We'll just delete it. Yeah.
We're good. It it was there. Okay.
So I've got the packet API token here.
Copy.
Yeah. The problem with the first one because
I could see it just The space. In
there. Yeah. The space. The space in front
of it. Yep.
Yep.
It's that trivial.
So getting
a change? Alright. It is done. So let's
go here and let's look
at our servers.
They're deploying. So we can see here exactly
what's happening just like we did before.
This will take a little longer than our
our
deploy that we did a couple weeks ago
when we were showing how to do this
through UI
because, of course, we're
provisioning the server and then installing
NGINX on it.
Well, main takes a few minutes too. So
will I swap just now and then we'll
come back to you? Yeah. Let's do that.
You can go on and spin yours up.
And then we'll we'll check them both to
make sure they work and we'll be good
to go.
Nice.
Okay. So let's see what I have.
So I'm using Pulumi and TypeScript.
That's my favorite combination of infrastructures code these
days.
Now the reason why, I'll explain.
In fact, I should spin this up first.
This is where I'm pulling me up.
So it's gonna create a salt master and
two salt minions. We'll hit yes.
Go away. Okay. So
the reason I like using Pulumi and TypeScript
is that I can define helper functions and
you'll see I'm using a few of them
here already. So the first one I do
is usually I provide some sort of platform
which is like a god object I guess
where I store the
the state of the universe.
I then have a helper function called create
assault master which just takes in the platform
and a name and then we export the
IPv4 address so that it can be consumed
by other scripts.
I then have another helper function called create
assault minion which takes the platform and name,
but then also the master because we have
to configure where that master actually is.
And we can specify the, you know, the
type of machine that we're looking to use
in the operating system.
And I've just made that so that we
can have a bit of a heterogeneous
cluster even though I'm not specifically doing that
anyway.
The platform object
really just as a wrapper around some config
that is required right now so you can
see that the project ID is returned and
that's really it for the moment. I won't
go through all of this code but our
salt master, we
actually interpret
some Python code that we use for salt
grains which I'll talk about later.
We then specify all the bits and pieces
that we need and we pass on the
user data which we are rendering also using
mustache.
One of the really cool things about using
TypeScript is I have access to all of
NPM which is pretty sweet.
Now this is what we pass into the
user data.
So you know,
we've got an apt get update, we install
salt, we have to kinda work out where
the
what address to bind the salt master on,
so the only lessons on the private network
and not the public network and that's what
I'm doing when I write this configuration.
We also configure the salt master as its
own minion
so that it can be provisioned by itself,
very meta
and then we configure the startup state. So
we're actually telling this salt machine, hey, when
you start the minion process, make sure you're
in a high state. A high state is
just what salt calls
reconciliation.
It just means hey,
install or provision or configure whatever we need
to on this machine every time the salt
menu starts.
I'm also using a guest which I'll show
you in just a second
because what happens with this user data is
that it installs salt and then we use
this guest as a representation of our
provisioning, our configuration management repository.
I guess it was just an easy way
to do that and then we render the
template and accept the key.
Let's see. Grab one more tab.
And
my guest is as basic as can be.
So
although your configuration management repository will be a
little bit more sophisticated than this.
For now, I just wanna show
much in the same way that Tom and
Jeremy are doing too is that we can
install NGINX here and you don't have to
worry about what a top fail is. This
is just a salt construct. We'll take a
look at that later.
Back over to you Tom, we'll come back
when mains is done.
Oh, I just
just booted Tom.
I meant to stop sharing my screen.
You meant you'll need to share your screen
again, Tom. Sorry about that. Alright. So we
can see here this has
run.
It built our
it provisioned our server. Now what we're gonna
do is live check and make sure we
are
everything worked correctly and see if we have
our NGINX server.
And good news. We got exactly what we
expected. So this all worked. Again, like
David said,
your setup, your configuration,
your
I guess all of this is gonna be
different. This is just for a very basic
NGINX server that we're not actually doing anything
with yet just to show how it works.
And I don't think that was enough time
for yours to provision, was it?
I I think I I spoke enough that
mine's probably finished.
Let me let let's check. Alright?
New.
Yeah. It's still creating okay. Because I'm using,
there's a good point actually.
There's a dependency in my setup and you
can see
when we
create the minions,
they have a hard dependency on the salt
master existing because they need to configure.
They need the IP address of the salt
master. So that's why mains is not happening
in parallel. So my salt master has to
get healthy first before that IP address can
be passed on to the minions. So mine
as well take a few more minutes because
of that dependency.
Yours is just phoning home right now.
Is mine phoning home? Mhmm. I guess, yeah.
I could always pull up the Echinox console
right now.
Which project?
It'll be this one. Seven one five eight?
Yeah. That's the one.
Come on, internet.
I know I'm streaming but you're better than
this.
We have a hello from Atikris eighty four.
Atikris.
I just had to go again. There we
go.
Let's see what our wonderful progress bar says
that is phoning home. Let's copy the IP
address.
I'll just try and get on it already.
That's a good sign.
Ignore that bit.
Alright. So let's see how far into the
setup we are.
Is it done? Okay. Cool.
So
this user data
on the salt master side,
know, install as a salt master and a
salt minion. Right? So that can provision itself.
And then automatically
accepts its own key
because
I'm gonna trust that nothing could interfere with
that setup in that moment in time and
that process. I do not automatically set the
keys from the subsequent menu nodes because that
would be an attack vector that I'm not
allowing to protect against right now. All that
means is that if I run salt key
dash l,
we'll see that the master was automatically accepted
and really to be honest because that's already
happened, I am gonna assume
I have NGINX which I do.
Alright, we're two for two.
I'm not finished yet Tom. Alright. I was
just celebrating. I'm excited.
So we have installed NGINX on the Saltmaster
but we should now be in a position
where Pulumi is spinning up our two menu
notes as well. So what's gonna happen here
is those two menu notes are gonna come
online. They're gonna be configured with the IP
address from my salt master. They're gonna send
a key request to the salt master
and I should be able to accept that
key request too.
And when I do the high state that
we've defined as a startup state will run
on the menu machines and also provision NGINX.
I
guess we can trust me for now that
it works rather than giving us the few
minutes that we need. I mean, let's see
how far We can check back. We're not
very far yet. Alright. Yeah. So we we
can always check back at that and then
we can talk about future
potential Jeremy.
It's a good thing about doing this together.
When one of when we stall, we can
pass it on. Right?
Perfect.
Alright. Where are we? Extra screen.
Jeremy's like, shit. I thought I had more
time.
I'll take the
yeah. Where are we at? We're talking
using Terraform to add Cloudinet to
one of our metal servers. So I will
show
my
Metal Monday Terraform config.
And so that's gonna look very much like
the
one that we saw in in weeks past.
We can probably provide a provide a link
to that, but
our provider
still named packet, so that'll still work.
You've seen the portion with a project ID
and so on. The,
only two parts here that are changed
are adding a
template
file,
an example from our friends at HashiCorp that
has brings up a Go web application,
and,
that'll be
injected into the user data when our
machine that we're calling Metal Monday, a t
one small in New Jersey with Ubuntu
and our
SSH key
comes up.
And so
going over to
I will drop in here what the
what that particular ad web app YAML file
looks like.
And that's just getting
a go link package,
make me a directory,
putting that in the path, and then grabbing
the example code from
GitHub.
And then now
that looks like
there is a I had the foresight
to to poke the button
and
and bring up that machine already, and let's
see if it's in our
in our dashboard.
Yeah. There's one called OpenNebula.
And so if I if I rerun that,
it'll probably give it the give it the
correct name.
But it looks like that is
up and running.
And we'll
check back into that machine in just a
moment to see if it's run the
run that cloud in it.
Okay.
Do you have a I Let's swipe back
to you let's swipe back to yours for
validation real quick.
So mine's just finished.
Thank you for filling up some time.
So
the menus were much quicker than my slot
master, which was good. Plus they could happen
concurrently because there was no dependencies.
So what that means is
we can
browse to here and
I've not checked. There
won't be any NGINX yet,
of course, because we have the key problem.
So
if I hit there, yep. Not working.
So we can jump back onto that salt
master.
Is that the right IP address? Nope. I've
just used an old one.
Let's
copy that.
Okay. I had it here, didn't I? There
we go. We can run salt key dash
l and what we should see now is
that we have two unaccepted keys from menu
one and menu two.
I can just go ahead and say accept
all of those. I'm pretty confident that those
are the two machine types back.
Run stop key dash l and we now
have three accepted keys.
Now I'm not gonna do anything else because
we're gonna rely on the high state startup
state to do everything that we need.
Which means,
if I hit refresh,
we now have NGINX across all of those
machines.
That was fast.
Yeah. Cell stack is ridiculously
fast. That was fast. You know, if I
do like salt star test a ping, know,
we can execute arbitrary commands on all of
these. I really do love salt stack.
Let's do
who am I?
You know, so I mean, I think that's
one of the superpowers of salt and I
won't spend too much time on it because
it's the premise or the concept of what
we're trying to portray today. But I definitely
will be doing much more content on salt.
As that is an event queue driven system,
when every time we execute a command here
or test up paying or any sort of
state that we want to run, it publishes
a message on the queue which are consumed
concurrently and in parallel by all the minion
machines who then send a response back along
the event bus. So it scales ridiculously.
Doesn't matter if you're running a single machine
or thousands of machines, SaltStack is a pretty
wicked tool.
And
you know, guest was really simple.
You know, this is what it took to
install NGINX for me to use the machines.
I just say, hey, there's this package called
NGINX and I want you to install it
for me and it just kinda works.
So very very cool software.
Yeah. Awesome. I'm very happy with that.
I am too. I'm pretty impressed by the
speed.
Yeah. Definitely.
Especially comparing it to what we were just
doing with Ansible. Right?
So I mean, I guess we can talk
about the differences between these these approaches and
then the cloud and that one as well
is that,
you know. So
bootstrapping process is very different from what you
did, from what I did and and what
Jeremy is doing for each of those. We
can I guess if we wanna talk about
the pros and cons or anything like that,
but
your process
Tom was
you run Ansible in your own machine
Mhmm?
To speak to the Equinix metal API, the
provision and instance, the user data that you
write as a bash script which installs Ansible,
pulls down an Ansible playbook and then runs
it.
That is great for people that are familiar
with Ansible,
but there's no constant reconciliation.
Ansible is
Ansible is a task winner
and so if you want to if you
want to reprovision that machine or make sure
that it always stays in checks and the
only option that you have is to have
a cron job that runs every hour, every
day, every week and runs the same playbook
and runs the same playbook.
What's different to the salt approach is that
I have Pulumi which spends up the instance,
it writes the bash script user data, so
very similar to what you did.
My user data also installs salt but once
salt is running,
it runs forever.
It's continually setting there running, it's gonna always
make sure that the state that we need
to be in, that's what the high state
means, it's like make sure this machine is
always in the state.
And salt will make sure that if engine
x is ever removed, it re installs it,
if the fail gets changed, it reconfigures it
etcetera. So the slightly different ways of working
depending on your use case.
Sure. The downside to my approach is that
salt is always running.
SALT does, SALT is not
it's had CVEs as recently as last week,
you know. So
when I,
what I mean by that, I'll try not
to mince my words too much but
I can run any command I want on
this machine.
Alright. I mean I don't care about these
boxes anymore and that should fail because it
should tell me that I need no preserve
root.
So
there we go.
So I didn't blow away those boxes but
you can see how dangerous that
is.
So if someone can't We can can see
it see it.
Oh.
Oh, yeah. There we go. Yay.
So you could see I I have to
speak for the audience. Yes. Thanks. I I
was thought I was still sharing my screen.
But you could see how dangerous the salt
master running there. Now I've taken some precautions
and that a, I only bind the salt
API to the private network on the Equinix
metal machines. Right? So like, there's no public
attack vector here.
However, have other software on the machines which
then exposes the host to that attacker, they
then have access to they have the ability
to run any arbitrary command across my entire
infrastructure
at a drop of a hat.
So yeah, reconciliation,
that style is great but we have to
be careful about that being used as an
attack factor. As I said, Salt has had
CVEs
last week and had CVEs last year. It's
always gonna have CVEs probably for remote code
execution.
So keep it patched, keep updated, but you
know, there's a lot of power in having
that available to us. Whereas Ansible
doesn't have that attack surface because we have
to initiate that task run, it's not always
there etcetera. So pros and cons to both
is I guess really what I was saying.
Unsure. What I would suggest, I mean, if
if you're watching and you have questions,
maybe we can try and
Jeremy, you want to show anything else? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. We're
Before I just keep waffling and take up
all of our time.
We're back to screen number two. And so
I was going to once the once the
machine had come up,
take and
go visit it.
So
drag a terminal back in here. Perfect.
That's the IP
of the
docs, which is
that's coming from here. And so here is
our
here is our dashboard.
Right now, we have
80 1 40 7 70 5 70 8
11.
Telling you this makes no difference because you
don't have my
private key.
And so
we are on that
there now. If we want to see what
what
went into this machine as user data,
we can take and click on the
correct window here.
There it is. Yep. So we said we
want the packages
go and go.
We want to create a
create that directory,
put it in the path, and get
and
we pulled down that code from GitHub.
Looks like that was the thing that happened.
I'm trapped on the edge of my screen
because I'm running a second one here.
And they're arrayed up and down instead of
side by side because, of course, they are.
Nice.
Okay. We will swap over to
That should've been a thing. Is there a
code there?
Yeah. You're in the home directory and not
the home Terraform.
Yeah.
Okay.
I wanna be in, Go.
Rawkode.
Yeah.
There should be a
So, I mean,
I could try and speculate if you want
or do you want a minute? I mean
No. Go for it.
So
it looks like
the run commands have happened. Right? Because I
do see the go terraform go and export
path. The directory is there.
But yeah. I'm assuming the go get failed.
I mean, can confirm that. There's a code
and a log output and bar log, etcetera.
We could take a look in that and
see what happens.
But I think it was close.
Yeah. I could either do that or just
go grab it go
go grab it again, but that sort of
defeats the purpose.
Alright. We could just talk about it a
certain way because I think, like, we still
got a few questions we can answer.
Sure enough.
So I don't know about
y'all,
but when I speak to people,
you know, one of the one of the
challenges that they have is like there there's
really good tooling and we've covered many examples
of this now about how do I get
a machine on Equinix metal.
But then the the challenge after that is
is how, you know, the bootstrapping process, what
we're covering today is how do I get
something on it that can then provision what
I want? Like I have configuration management and
I have the ability to spin up the
devices, how do I manage them together? And
I think,
you know, the three examples we've provided today
of using user data or using cloud in
it to then bootstrap the machine to get
it in a position where it can begin
to function, to serve software, to serve users,
etcetera. It's just something that can be a
little bit tricky to navigate and I think
we were showing three really practical ways of
handling that step.
I mean, I think Mainz is the best,
but, you know, no disrespect to Clued in
it or Ansible, but I'm a big soul
advocate.
I think it's an awesome tool.
Anything you just wanna add?
Yeah. I suppose that's not those aren't the
only ones just as we showed multiple ways
to do things before. There's the there's the
language SDKs.
The you can you can accomplish the same
thing because all of these
all of these methods are using the API.
And so if you wanna make handcrafted artisanal
API requests or roll your own for a
very specific use case,
you can go you can go that way
also.
Yeah. Definitely.
There's
definitely many, many ways to cover this this
this gap, I guess.
Tom?
He's got
Tom, you're on mute. You're on mute. Again,
man. Nope. Yes. Yes. There are sorry. I
had a barking dog I didn't think everybody
would wanna listen to.
We like dogs here.
I have a my my dogs were yipping
at the front door, so not the most
exciting noise in the background. But now that
I guess I took the time to explain
that, it would have been just easier to
let them bark. Right?
Or you could just remember to unmute and
be professional.
Ouch.
Too harsh for the morning time. I forget
that it's early for you both.
Alright. I'll rain the sarcasm in.
Yeah, I think we've shown some really cool
tools here. I mean, Ansible and Salt Sack
are really popular. Cloud on it is extremely
popular too, know. Being comfortable with these tools
and understanding how to apply them in this
in this form, I think is really important.
And let us know or reach out to
us on Twitter or in the comment section
and let us know what else or problems
you have scaling your bare metal deployments and
we'll be sure to purchase more content with
some solutions and I'm sure many more challenges
as well.
Yep. What is that what is that Twitter
account?
On you go, Tom.
Oh, at equinix
metal, e q u I n I x
metal, m e t a l. And, yeah,
you can ask any questions. We'd love to
start getting more involvement from you all, letting
us know what you wanna hear on Metal
Mondays.
K. We also hang out on Slack.
And as you might expect, that's slack.equinixmetal.com
and available for
questions. Or if you've done something that you're
very proud of and would like to show
it off, I'd love to see it. Yep.
For sure.
Awesome. Well, thank you for joining us again.
We will be back next Monday with more
cool stuff. I don't know what that is
yet. We'll need to
have a quick consult.
But we will do something extremely awesome. Right?
Hopefully,
maybe. Kinda.
Extremely
awesome and totally metal. I've got nowhere to
go here. Some did take me out this
hole really quickly, but
That's when you just end with a quick
buy and kill the feed. Right? Yeah. We
work. Yeah. Yeah. I I think mom's calling.
Alright.
We'll be back next week. Thank you for
tuning in, and we'll speak to you all
soon. Have a nice day. Cheers. Happy Monday.